dinnertime with this female centipede
here in Africa on the menu fresh
grasshopper when this centipede goes out
to eat
she doesn't hire a babysitter nope she
packs her young securely in the tender
trap of her own back legs warmth
security togetherness centipede Family
Values when it's time to put the kids to
bed all she does is lift up her rear end
and march home out in the African night
on her own she draws the attention of a
predator this small black headed snake
whose diet is comprised mainly of
centipedes the snake attacks the
centipede mom fights back in defense but
the snake holds on with hungry
determination the snake's venom works
and the centipede is a goner now the
snake has the same problem as a dog that
chases after a school bus what does it
do when it catches it
[Music]
the centipedes body is almost twice as
wide as the snake not that this stops
the snake starting with the head the
snake swallows the centipede hole
gulping down every last lake at least
the babies weren't along for the ride
this time